>> Laura: ALL RIGHT, WELCOME
BACK TO "THE INGRAHAM ANGLE".
LAS VEGAS, ALMOST FOUR MONTHS
AFTER THE DEADLY MASS SHOOTING,
WORST IN AMERICAN HISTORY.
WHY SO MANY UNANSWERED
QUESTIONS?
LET’S TURN TO A COUPLE OF
EXPERTS TO BREAK IT DOWN.
FORMER LAPD DETECTIVE MARK
FUHRMAN, WHO BECAME A HOUSEHOLD
NAME DURING THE O.J. SIMPSON
TRIAL.
AND RANDY SUTTON, FORMER LT.
WITH THE LAS VEGAS METROPOLITAN
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
GREAT TO SEE BOTH OF YOU.
MARK, LET’S START WITH YOU.
IT IS FOUR MONTHS, ALMOST, SINCE
THE SHOOTING.
WE’RE NOW ONLY HEARING THAT THEY
MIGHT BE CHARGING ANOTHER
INDIVIDUAL AFTER WE’VE HEARD
ALMOST NOTHING FROM THE
LAS VEGAS POLICE DEPARTMENT,
AFTER THE PRESS HAD TO PRESS FOR
A LOT OF THESE DOCUMENTS TO BE
RELEASED.
WHAT’S GOING HERE?
>> WELL, LAURA, LET’S PAUSE FOR
A SECOND AND UNDERSTAND THAT WE
HAD 58 HOMICIDES, 58 INDIVIDUAL
HOMICIDE INVESTIGATIONS.
AND HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE THAT WERE
WOUNDED AND THAT HAD TO BE
DOCUMENTED AND HANDLED BY THE
DETECTIVES.
WE HAVEN’T HEARD FROM ONE
DETECTIVE, WHICH IS UNFORTUNATE.
LET’S LOOK AT SOME OF THE THINGS
THAT HAD TO BE PROCESSED.
ONE IS DNA.
IF THERE WAS DNA ON ANYTHING
THAT PADDOCK HAND THALD WAS IN
THAT ROOM, THEY PROBABLY PURSUED
THAT.
IT IS PROBABLY HIS GIRLFRIEND
THAT, THEY’RE ACTUALLY
TARGETING.
I DON’T THINK THAT’S GOING TO
SOLVE ANYTHING IN THIS CASE AS
FAR AS WHY, THE MOTIVE, OR
REALLY HOW PADDOCK PULLED THIS
OFF.
>> Laura: RANDY, YOU ARE A
VETERAN OF THE LAS VEGAS POLICE
DEPARTMENT, I HAVE A COUPLE OF
FRIENDS THAT YOU PROBABLY KNOW
WHO ARE HOMICIDE DETECTIVES
THERE, JUST RETIRED A COUPLE OF
YEARS AGO.
AND IT’S A TIGHT KNIT GROUP AT
THE LAS VEGAS POLICE.
THEY DEAL WITH A LOT EVERY DAY.
BUT THIS WAS SO HORRIFIC ON
EVERY LEVEL.
WHAT HAPPENS WHEN WE DON’T HAVE
A REGULAR UPDATE, OR EVEN PRESS
BRIEFINGS, I THINK, IN A CASE
LIKE THIS IS THAT PEOPLE START
SAYING WHAT’S REALLY GOING ON.
WELL WHY AREN’T WE SEEING --
WHERE’S THE VIDEO OF HIM
CHECKING INTO THE HOTEL.
I’VE BEEN ASKING THIS QUESTION,
MY PRODUCERS LAUGH AT ME, I ASK
THE QUESTION EVERY DAY, WHERE’S
THE VIDEO OF STEVE GENERAL
PADDOCK CHECKING INTO THE HOTEL.
>> THERE’S A LOT GOING ON HERE.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT YOU
PROBABLY HEARD, HAS BEEN
UNEXAPPLICABLE TO ME, IS THAT
METRO TOOK ON THIS INVESTIGATION
AND THE SCOPE OF IT, OF COURSE,
IS HUGE, FOR SOME REASON A
DECISION WAS MADE TO RELIEVE THE
HOMICIDE UNIT OF THE
INVESTIGATION AND GIVE IT TO A
RATHER INNOCUOUS UNIT THAT
HANDLES OFFICER-INVOLVED
SHOOTINGS.
THAT’S ONE OF THE MAJOR
QUESTIONS THAT I HAVE HAD.
HERE’S THE THING, THE INITIAL
LAW ENFORCEMENT RESPONSE WAS
AMAZING.
COURAGE THAT THESE OFFICERS
SHOWED AND THE DEDICATION THEY
SHOWED WAS ABSOLUTELY STUNNING.
BUT THEN YOU HAVE THIS MEDIA
BLACKOUT, AS YOU HAVE TERMED IT,
AND IT’S VERY DIFFICULT TO
UNDERSTAND.
IT’S A LITTLE INEXPLICABLE TO
ME, HOW THE SHERIFF HAS NOT BEEN
KEEPING THE PUBLIC --
>> Laura: I KNOW YOU AREN’T
GOING TO SAY THIS, RANDY, BUT
DID THEY SCREW UP?
OR ARE THEY WORRIED THAT VEGAS,
I MEAN, IT’S A PLACE THAT
SURVIVES ON TOURISM.
PEOPLE HAVE TO FEEL SAFE.
THEY HAVE TO FEEL LIKE WHEN THEY
CHECK INTO A HOTEL THERE’S NOT A
GUY CHECKING TEN BAGS WITH
THOUSANDS OF ROUNDS OF
AMMUNITION IN THE NEXT HOTEL
ROOM.
I GET THESE CASINOS, THEY WANT
TO BE THRIVING AND HIRING
PEOPLE.
I GET IT.
I FIND THIS WOULD BE REALLY ODD.
FRANKLY, INFURIATING, WE GOT THE
BIG BRUSHOFF FROM THE POLICE
TODAY, WE’RE BIG SUPPORTERS OF
THE POLICE, BIG BRUSHOFF.
WHAT DO YOU MEAN YOU’RE NOT
GOING TO TALK ABOUT IT?
WE AREN’T ASKING YOU TO XREE HIZ
THE INVESTIGATION.
WHY DO WE KNOW SO LITTLE ABOUT
HIS MOVEMENTS INSIDE THAT HOTEL,
NO ONE EVER WENT INSIDE THE
HOTEL CAN HIM, NO ONE CAME IN
AND OUT, NO MAIDS?
WHERE’S THAT SECURITY GUARD, HE
WAS ON "ELLEN," HE DID ONE
APPEARANCE ON "ELLEN," HE HAS
SOME DEAL WITH THE MANDALAY BAY
HOTEL.
>> DID THE POLICE SCREW UP, NO,
THEY DIDN’T.
THEY HAVE HANDLED THIS
INVESTIGATION AT THE INITIAL
OUTSET, WITH THE PROFESSIONALISM
THAT ONE WOULD EXPECT.
HOWEVER, YOU KNOW, WHEN YOU TALK
ABOUT GIVING THE RESPONSIBILITY
OF THIS INVESTIGATION TO THE
PROPER AUTHORITIES, WELL THAT
WOULD BE THE HOMICIDE UNIT.
>> Laura: THOSE GUYS ARE GREAT,
I KNOW THEM, GREAT GUYS.
I HAVE TO GET FUHRMAN IN ON
THIS.
MARK, I DON’T -- I’M A BIG
SUPPORTER OF THE POLICE,
EVERYONE KNOWS THAT.
BUT THIS WAS, WE HAVE 58
AMERICANS DEAD, WE HAD 498
INJURED, WE’RE NOT GOING TO
RELEASE THIS SEARCH WARRANT, NOT
GOING TO RELEASE THAT SEARCH
WARRANT.
WE HAVE ONE WOMAN WHO GOT PAID
MONEY WHILE THIS THING WAS
HAPPENING, HE WIRED HER MONEY,
SHE DELETED HER FACEBOOK
ACCOUNT, BEFORE HIS NAME WAS
RELEASED TO THE PUBLIC SHE’S
DELETING FACEBOOK ACCOUNTS.
THAT WAS ODD.
>> WELL, LAURA, RANDY IS
ABSOLUTELY CORRECT, I THINK IT’S
SLAP IN THE FACE OF THE HOMICIDE
DETECTIVES THAT DO THIS FOR A
LIVING, OFFICER-INVOLVED
SHOOTING TEAM DEAL WITH DEATHS
BUT USUALLY INVOLVES OFFICERS.
I’M SURE THAT THE THOUGHT
PROCESS WAS THAT THEY HANDLE A
LOT OF BALLISTICS AND A LOT OF
TRACKING, THE PATH OF BULLETS,
THEY WOULD BE BETTER, I GUESS,
INFORMED TO HANDLE THIS SINCE
THE SHOOTER IS DEAD.
THAT BEING SAID, THE ONE THING I
DIDN’T LIKE ABOUT THIS
INVESTIGATION, YOU HAD TOO MANY
HEAVIES, TOO MANY CHIEFS, TOO
MANY FROM THE BIG TOWER TALKING
IN THESE PRESS CONFERENCES
INSTEAD PEOPLE THAT DO THIS FOR
A LIVING.
I THINK THAT’S ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT BECAME A MISTAKE THAT NOW
WE DON’T HAVE THAT INFORMATION,
WE ALSO HAVE CIVIL LITIGATION,
WE HAVE HUNDREDS OF CIVIL
LAWSUITS THAT ARE UNDOUBTEDLY
WE’RE LOOKING AT.
THE CITY OF LAS VEGAS, MANDALAY
BAY, THE POLICE DEPARTMENT, EVEN
THOUGH I BELIEVE JUST LIKE
RANDY, THE POLICE DEPARTMENT DID
NOTHING, THEY HAD SUCH A SMALL
WINDOW TO ACTUALLY ACT.
AND I THINK THEY DID IT AS HE’S
PUT, BRAVELY AND HEROICALLY,
THEY ACTUALLY CLOSED AS FAST AS
THEY COULD WITH THE SUSPECT.
BUT MANDALAY BAY AND LAS VEGAS
AND AN ELECTED OFFICIAL THAT’S
HANDLING THE INVESTIGATION AS
SHERIFF, I THINK THERE’S A LOT
OF UNSAID POLITICS GOING ON
HERE.
>> Laura: BINGO, FOLLOW THE
MONEY.
>> I BELIEVE THEY’RE JUST
SLOWING IT DOWN.
>> Laura: FOLLOW THE MONEY.
>> THERE’S NO DOUBT IN MY MIND,
NO DOUBT IN MY MIND THE MANDALAY
BAY IS THE ONE CONTROLLING --
>> Laura: THE INFORMATION FLOW.
>> ESPECIALLY WHEN IT COMES TO
THE EMPLOYEE, CAMPOS.
I MEAN, HE DISAPPEARED AFTER